bienvenue dans vue de Russie le magazine
hebdomadaire qui analyse la propagande
de Vladimir Poutine sur fond de guerre
en Ukraine avec Elena Volochine comme
chaque semaine bonsoir Elena bonsoir
Stéphanie cette semaine le 9 mai et bien
la Russie a célébré la fête de la
victoire celle de l'Union soviétique
contre l'Allemagne nazie sur fond de
guerre en Ukraine on peut dire que la
propagande russe rejoue aujourd'hui ce
qui est présenté comme une guerre sainte
contre le nazisme oui vu de Russie le 9
mai c'est le moment où la propagande qui
justifie cette invasion de l'Ukraine par
la Russie atteint son paroxysme et pour
la deuxième année consécutive puisque
c'est la deuxième année de cette
invasion à grande échelle donc cette
fête elle a été vécue dans la continuité
de ce qui est qualifié en Russie la
grande guerre patriotique et ce qui est
qualifié en Russie d'opération militaire
spéciale en Ukraine et ce soir là donc
cette semaine le 9 mai les grands
journaux télévisés du soir russe ont
bien entendu ouvert sur le défilé
militaire annuel sur la Place Rouge et
le discours de Vladimir Poutine temps
fort de ses célébrations à regarder
le 9 mai est une fête sacrée pour notre
pays cette année les participants à
l'opération militaire spéciale ont eux
aussi défilé à la parade ceux qui
aujourd'hui défendent notre pays d'une
nouvelle menace
l'exploit des ancêtres qui ont défendu
l'alternatal reste l'exemple le plus
éclatant de l'amour pour la patrie même
après plusieurs décennies y compris pour
ceux qui combattent à nouveau le nazisme
une vraie guerre et de nouveaux menées
contre notre pays
né du revanchisme frontal de ceux qui
préparent uniquement et ouvertement une
nouvelle campagne contre la Russie pour
ça ils ont rassemblé les démons de
néo-nazis du monde entier leur but et ce
n'est pas nouveau et de parvenir à
l'éclatement et à la destruction de
notre pays
finalement c'est un discours que
Vladimir Poutine a répété quasiment mot
pour mot il a répété mot pour mot ce
qu'il a dit il y a un an au même endroit
pour justifier sa guerre contre
l'Ukraine oui la réitéré tous les dogmes
fondateurs de ce mythe celui de
l'agression préventive avec ses supposés
menaces imminente de dest de la Russie
l'ennemi évidemment ce sont les
Occidentaux qui rassemblent leurs vasies
leur vassaux pardon nazis contre la
Russie l'Occident qui selon ses discours
aurait voulu annuler les valeurs
traditionnelles en russe bref c'est
fantasme que vous Vladimir Poutine
répète désormais sans arrêt sur fond de
guerre en Ukraine mais il y a aussi
cette propagande qui est chargée de les
décliner à longueur de journée et pour
cela elle s'appuie sur le soutien actif
d'une partie de la population russe quel
abreuve et qui la nourrit en retour du
coup le 9 mai se mythe d'une grande
Russie qui rejoue la guerre contre le
nazisme se déploie en trois dimensions
comme par exemple dans les rues de
Moscou replonger pour l'occasion dans
l'ambiance d'un neuf mai 45 regardez
une fois la parade achevée la fête s'est
emparée des rues de Moscou
[Musique]
une autre tradition immuable la valse de
la victoire sur la ville centrale
[Musique]
et voici des images rares de 1945 la
victoire tant attendue Moscou a fait la
fête pendant plusieurs jours on célèbre
toujours cette fête avec les larmes aux
yeux ce sont des larmes de joie et de
reconnaissance
c'est notre victoire et elle vivra elle
vivra toujours le peuple russe est
invincible avec cette ambiance festive à
Moscou on n'a pas du tout sentiment que
pays connaît les horreurs de la guerre
non parce que finalement il n'y a pas de
guerre c'est une opération spéciale une
opération spéciale qui est toujours
présentée en Russie comme une campagne
noble juste sacrée et inévitablement
victorieuse malgré les difficultés sur
le front la propagande russe elle
maintient la population dans cet état de
perfusion d'un patriotisme exacerbé ça
passe par d'un côté la censure avec
l'interdiction pure et simple d'exprimer
tout autre sentiment que celui que vous
avez entendu dans cet extrait de l'autre
c'est de propagande qui met toujours en
avant les soutiens du régime ces voix
qui le soutiennent et qui sont les
seules autorisés à retentir en public
sur fond de la répression envers tous
ceux qui pensent différemment
voyez donc cet autre séquence ça se
passe sur la Place Rouge avec ses maires
de soldats et de mobiliser les mêmes qui
ont déjà été interrogés par la
télévision russe
ici sur la Place Rouge nous croisons
les maires des participants à
l'opération spéciale que le président a
rencontré il y a quelques mois dans sa
résidence
chacun là-bas est un héros chacun porte
cette victoire sur ses épaules la
victoire de nos grands-parents et notre
victoire future qui a viendra sans nul
doute parce que ce sont les meilleurs
les plus courageux les plus vaillants
qui sont là-bas
sacrée menée par de valeureux
combattants passent aussi par des
reportages depuis la ligne de front oui
un œuf mais c'est reportages montrent à
l'oeuvre ce que la version officielle
russe qualifie d'héritier dont le sang
des vainqueurs coule dans les veines
c'est une formule qui est sans cesse
répéter comme d'autres slogans par les
chaînes de télévision russe des
héritiers qui accompliraient aujourd'hui
la même tâche que leurs ancêtres
regardaient
le sang des vainqueurs coule dans nos
veines et on vaincra sans nul doute
si vous aujourd'hui sur la ligne de
front en plus de leur kalachnikov ils
ont emporté les portraits de leur
grand-père et arrière-grand-père qui
jaillissent ont déjà vaincus le nazisme
je l'ai pris avec moi pour qu'il voit
que comme on combat les fascistes
aujourd'hui les héros de la grande
guerre patriotique sont dans le rang
avec ceux qui combattent le néophéisme
en ce moment même on refait ce qu'on
fait nos grands-pères on chasse les
fascistes on anéant
les exploits du front de ces années-là
les héritiers les connaissent d'après
les récits mais ici ils en font
l'expérience par eux-mêmes
l'arrière-grand-père d'Anton a combattu
ici en 1943 aujourd'hui son arrière
petit-fils libère barnout
comme mon arrière-grand-père et tu
penses qu'il serait fier de toi
je pense que oui
c'est vraiment une version de l'histoire
très romanesque à entendre ses
combattants russes on se demande
forcément Elena dans quelle mesure ils
sont convaincus que cette romance de
existe véritablement de combattre les
nazis vous qui les avez côtoyés est-ce
que les Russes croient vraiment qu'il
combattent les nazis alors c'est une
question importante parce que c'est
celle de l'extrême efficacité finalement
de cette propagande avec cette jeune
population masculine qui est nourrie dès
le plus jeune âge en Russie encore plus
aujourd'hui avec cette guerre à grande
échelle nourri et élevé dans cette idée
qu'elle doit aller combattre et mourir
pour sa patrie pour honorer la mémoire
de ses grands-parents donc c'est encore
plus le cas je le disais avec cette
guerre qui est présentée comme la
nouvelle grande guerre patriotique au
détriment des faits vous l'avez entendu
dans ce reportage ces soldats à peine
majeurs ils disent que depuis l'enfance
il ne rêvait que d'une chose finalement
c'était de partir au front et comment
monter le plus croire justement à ce
mythe d'une Ukraine à libérer des nazis
et parce que depuis très longtemps déjà
cette propagande elle a plongé non
seulement les Russes mais aussi à les
populations des territoires qu'elle
envahissait en Ukraine dans une réalité
ou s'inverse les rôles entre l'agresseur
et l'agresser et ce à travers une
version biaisée des faits qu'on a
retrouvé cette semaine justement sur les
chaînes de télévision russe à l'occasion
du 9 mai par exemple avec un reportage à
Mario Paul qui revient sur les
événements du 9 mai 2014 à Mario Paul ce
jour-là comme dans d'autres villes du
Dombasle une confrontation a lieu entre
des bataillons ukrainiens et des
séparatistes locaux armés et dirigés par
Moscou qui prennent d'assaut le
commissariat de la ville appuyé donc par
des mercenaires et des agents des
services secrets russes le nouvel le
nouveau gouvernement pro-européen à Kiev
envoie ses bataillants suite à
l'annexion de la Crimée pour déloger ces
groupes armés il y a un échange de coups
de feu avec des morts des deux côtés
c'est comme ça que commence la guerre
dans le don-base sauf que la propagande
russe elle présente ses événements comme
je cite une expédition punitive des
nazis Ukrainiens qui seraient allés
attaquer des civils qui essayaient de
tenir une parade de la victoire en ce 9
mai 2014 à Mario Paul c'est ce que dit
cet extrait regardez
il y a 9 ans jour pour jour un défilé de
vétérans une manifestant Pacifique porte
les portraits des héros morts durant la
Grande Guerre Patriotique alors qu'ils
étaient sur le boulevard Lénine les
unités de la garde nationale ukrainienne
du bataillon Azov et de pravissator ont
accueilli les manifestants pacifiques
par des tirs de fusils de Grenade en
même temps que la fusillade contre les
défis des Pacifique les policiers
mutants de Mario Paul ont été massacrés
parce qu'il refusaient d'exécuter
l'ordre criminel de tirer sur le défilé
du 9 mai
pour cette ancienne prisonnière des
camps de concentration nazis le
néonazisme ukrainien et pire
c'est terrible c'est monstrueux les
Allemands ne faisaient pas ce que fait
l'Ukraine
il y a une version
oui une instrumentalisation donc de ses
populations locales abreuvées par cette
propagande qui leur faisait déjà croire
que des nazis venaient les massacrer
c'est là l'un des drames fondamentaux
finalement dans cette guerre à Mario
Paul aussi ville martyr au moins 22000
morts suite à l'invasion cette fois donc
à grande échelle et ouverte par la
Russie en 2023 aujourd'hui la ville est
occupée par les Russes et ce 9 mai 2023
justement et bien les mêmes célébrations
pour la Fête de la Victoire qu'en Russie
ont été tenues par par les occupants
avec les survivants qui sont restés donc
à Mario Paul regardez
sur les places et dans les rues de Mario
Paul en ce jour de la victoire des
milliers de personnes vont déposer des
fleurs devant le mémorial aux victimes
du fascisme je suis heureuse aujourd'hui
d'avoir un passeport russe et de pouvoir
venir déposer des fleurs pour le 9 mai
voilà c'est important de montrer ces
événements parce que c'est une
population civile ukrainienne doublement
victime de la guerre et de cette
propagande qui réécrit non seulement son
passé mais aussi son présent en érigeant
au rang de héros ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui responsables de la guerre et
de nombreux Ukrainiens qu'on appellera
les séparatistes prorus ils sont ralliés
à Vladimir Poutine sur la base de ce
mythe qui leur faisait voir le
gouvernement ukrainien comme des nazis
qui voulaient venir les massacrer et
c'est terrifiant merci Elena Elena
Volochine on vous retrouve donc la
semaine prochaine à la même heure 18h40
pour vue de Russie